the universe is teeming with planets I
want us in the next decade to build a
Space Telescope that'll be able to image
an earth about another star and figure
out whether it can harbor life my
colleagues at the NASA Jet Propulsion
Laboratory at Princeton and I are
working on technology that we'll be able
to do just that in the coming years
astronomers now believe that every star
in the galaxy has a planet and they
speculate that up to 1/5 of them have an
earth-like planet that might be able to
Harbor life but we haven't seen any of
them we've only detected them indirectly
this is NASA's famous picture of the
pale blue dot it was taken by the
Voyager spacecraft in 1990 when they
turned it around as it was exiting the
solar system to take a picture up of the
earth from 6 billion kilometres away I
want to take that of a earth-like planet
about another star why haven't we done
that why is that hard well to see let's
imagine we take the Hubble Space
Telescope and we turn it around and we
move it out to the orbit of Mars we'll
see something like that a slightly
blurry picture of the earth because
we're a fairly small telescope out of
the orbit of Mars now let's move 10
times further away here we are at the
orbit of Uranus it's gotten smaller it's
gotten less detail less resolved we can
still see the little moon let's go 10
times further away again here we are at
the edge of the solar system out at the
Kuiper belt now it's not resolved at all
it's that pale blue dot of Carl Sagan's
well let's move yet again 10 times
further away here we are out at the
Aurora cloud outside the solar system
and we're starting to see the Sun move
into the field of view and get into
where the planet is one more time ten
times further away now we're at Alpha
Centauri our nearest neighbor star and
the planet is gone all we're seeing is
that big beaming image of the star
that's 10 billion times brighter than
the planet which should be in that
little red circle that's what we want to
see that's why it's hard the light from
the star is diffracting it's scattering
inside the telescope creating that very
bright image that washes out the planet
so to see the planet we have to
something about all of that light we
have to get rid of it I have a lot of
colleagues working on really amazing
technologies to do that but I want to
tell you about one today that I think is
the coolest and probably the most likely
to get us an earth in the next decade
it was first suggested by Lyman Spitzer
the father of the Space Telescope in
1962 and he took his inspiration from an
eclipse y'all seen that that's a solar
eclipse the moon has moved in front of
the Sun it blacks out most of the light
so we can see that dim Corona around it
maybe the same thing if I put my thumb
up and block that spot light that's
getting right in my eye I can see you in
the back row well what's going on well
the moon is casting a shadow down on the
earth we put a telescope or a camera in
that shadow we look back at the Sun and
most of the lights been removed and we
can see that dim fine structure in the
corona Spitzer suggestion was we do this
in space we build a big screen we fly it
in space we put it up in front of the
star we block that most of the light we
fly a Space Telescope in that shadow
that's created and boom we get to see
planets well that would look something
like this so there's that big screen and
there's no planets because unfortunately
it doesn't actually work very well
because the light waves of the light and
waves diffracts around that screen the
same way it did in the telescope it's
like water bending around a rock in a
stream and all that light just destroys
the shadow it's a terrible shadow and we
can't see planets but spits are actually
knew the answer if we can feather the
edges soften those edges so we can
control diffraction well then we can see
a planet in the last ten years or so
we've come up with optimal solutions for
doing that it looks something like that
we call that our flower petal star shade
if we make the edges of those petals
exactly right if we control their shape
we can control diffraction and now we
have a great shadow it's about ten
billion times dimmer than it was before
and we can see the planets beam out just
like that that of course has to be
bigger than my thumb that star shade is
about the size of half a football field
and it has to fly 50 thousand kilometers
away from the telescope that has to be
held right in its shadow and then we can
see those planets this sounds formidable
but brilliant engineers colleagues of
JPL came up with a fabulous design for
how to do that it looks like this starts
wrapped around a hub separates from the
telescope the pedals unfurl they open up
the telescope turns around then you'll
see it flip and fly out that fifty
thousand kilometers away from the
telescope it's going to move in front of
the star just like that creates a
wonderful shadow boom we get planets
orbiting about it thank you
that's not science fiction we've been
working on this for the last five or six
years last summer we did a really cool
test out in California at Northrop
Grumman so those are four petals this is
a subscale star shade it's about half
the size of the one you just saw you'll
see the petals unfurl those four petals
were built by four undergraduates doing
a summer internship at JPL now you're
seeing it deploy those petals have to
rotate into place
the base of those petals has to go to
the same place every time to within 1/10
of a millimeter we ran this test 16
times and 16 times that went into the
exact same place to a tenth of a
millimeter this has to be done very
precisely but if we can do this if we
can build this technology if we can get
it into space you might see something
like this that's a picture of one of our
nearest neighbor stars taken with the
Hubble Space Telescope if we can take a
similar space telescope slightly larger
put it out there flying a culture in
front of it what we might see is
something like that that's a family
portrait of our solar system but not
ours we're hoping it'll be someone
else's solar system as seen through an
occult er through a star shaped like
that you can see Jupiter you can see
Saturn Uranus Neptune and right there in
the center next to the residual light is
that pale blue dot that's earth we want
to see that see if there's water oxygen
ozone the things that might tell us that
it could Harbor life I think this is the
coolest possible science that's why I
got into doing this because I think that
will change the world that will change
everything when we see that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you